[Música]
una crónica de cultura que vamos a tener
hoy con nuestra compañera leurel Leal
bienvenida Buenas noches Rodrigo Buenas
noches lea vamos a ir al sur de Francia
directamente porque esta semana comenzó
el mayor acontecimiento cinematográfico
del mundo el festival de can y con
nosotros vamos a estar hoy hablando
contigo de este tema de la importancia
del festival y de todo lo que hemos
podido ver estos primeros días Así que
lea cuéntame qué hemos visto ahí en
cancán bueno Rodrigo como lo dijo
Michael Douglas existen centenas de
festivales en el mundo pero solo existe
un festival de can y es con esas
palabras que se abrió la edición número
76 de la cita imperdible del cine
mundial un evento que le hace honor a
las películas obviamente pero sobre todo
a los actores y actrices como el mismo
Michael Douglas que recibió durante la
ceremonia de apertura el martes una
palma de oro de honor por sus 55 años
Rodrigo de extraordina trayectora en el
cine y sorpresa ayer una segunda palma
de oro de honor fue regalada a Harrison
Ford del actor de 88 años llegó acá para
presentar El quinto y último episodio de
la saga de nuestro favorito aventurero
arqueológico Indiana Jones obviamente
hace más de 40 años que los fans
esperaban verlo de nuevo con su
emblemático sombrero y su látigo
Harrison Ford pareció muy conmovido de
recibir este premio honorífico y al
mismo tiempo de decir adiós a este
personaje tan mítico y otra película muy
esperada durante estos primeros días de
festivales la del director Martín
escorsese y de dos de sus actores
favoritos Robert de Niro y Leonardo
DiCaprio reunidos por primera vez en
Killers of the frio mundo Western de
tres horas y media que será presentado
mañana en la cuaset miremos el traidor
[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno olea Indiana Jones y Killers of
the Flower son dos películas que yo no
me quiero perder pero que aquí están
fuera de concurso realmente cuéntanos
qué pasa con las películas que entonces
forman parte del concurso oficial de Kan
Bueno este año son 21 las películas que
se enfrentan en esta categoría que es la
más prestigiosa y Desde el miércoles la
carrera para ganar la palma de oro se
puso en marcha por lo que can es ante
todo Una competencia a cada día muestran
dos nuevas películas al público a los
periodistas y obviamente a los miembros
del del Jurado y este año hay una cifra
en particular que llama la atención
siete de las 21 películas de la
selección oficial son firmadas por
directoras eso representa un tercio no
es paridad obviamente Rodrigo Pero ya es
un récord en la historia del festival y
dentro de estas siete directoras dos
representan el continente africano en la
carrera para la palma de oro La tunecina
y la Franco senegalesa ramata tulaiesi
lo interesante con esa última directora
es que vanelia dama es su primer
largometraje es una historia de amor
rodada en el norte de senegal y a mí me
da muchas ganas de descubrirla al revés
hay unos nombres bien conocidos dentro
de la selección oficial de este año el
británico Que el italiano moretí el
japonés
con al menos una palma de oro esos cinco
directores durante las presidentes
ediciones de can Entonces ellos hacen
parte del club de los habituales del
festival unas personas también les
llaman como los veteranos del del
festival son más asiduos que los propios
directivos quizás del festival y antes
de seguir quiero preguntarte para ti
Cuál es la favorita
yo creo que mucha gente está mirando del
lado de kenlotch además sobre esta
historia de de Palmas de oro que que él
ya ganó ya recibió dos y además la
película de Kenny Rogers el británico va
a ser su última también entonces sería
bastante lindo para el de recibir una
tercera palma de oro y así cerrar su su
carrera logremos estos pronósticos lea
Pero estas películas que se van a ver en
cannes van a llegar también ya a
nuestros cines o habrá que esperar
todavía tenemos que esperar un poquito
dentro de unos meses depende de cada
película pero pero yo por eso justamente
Rodrigo quería hablarles de
una película francesa que se llama Los
cinco diablos en español que fue
mostrada por primera vez en la quincena
de realizadores el año pasado en el
festival de Kan que es una sección que
permitió descubrir nuevos talentos desde
1900 1969 como Michael George Lucas
Los Hermanos darden
entonces personas bastante famosas me
parece que es una una buena una buena
señal de hacer parte de esta categoría y
lo bueno de los cinco diablos es que
esta película ustedes ya la pueden ver
se estrenó Hace unos días en América
Latina en la plataforma de streaming
movie es una cinta de fantasía y de
crecimiento con un ambiente misterioso
seguimos la historia de Vicky una niña
de 8 años bastante solitaria que puede
oler y Reproducir cualquier aroma que
desee y tuve la oportunidad de hablar
con su directora lea mississius la
escuchamos
quería hablar de cosas profundas que son
preguntas existenciales de una niña de 8
años que se pregunta por qué está en la
tierra si sus padres La querían antes
que pasó en la vida de su familia para
que sintiera el peso del secreto y de lo
no dicho pero no quería que fuera
demasiado cerebral y Pesado también
quería que fuera un placer para el
espectador que fuera lúdica ligera Pop
por eso la película tiene sus dos
vertientes un aspecto que utiliza los
códigos de la cultura pop de la música y
al mismo tiempo que hay en ese lado
carnal primitivo un poco extraño y sordo
y pesado pero que trabaja en nosotros
desde el interior y que de hecho es
cuando el espectador sale de la película
que de repente hay cosas que brotan que
no necesariamente lo notan
inmediatamente primero lo disfrutó tuvo
emociones espero estaba en el placer
inmediato y que después escarba algo
mucho más profundo
me recuerda un poco a la película el
perfume no lea este argumento sí
totalmente Sí sí Bueno pues veremos
cuando la podamos ver en los cines
seguro que vamos a estar allí Muchas
gracias por este repaso de cultura del
festival de can y que no recordarles
además a nuestro espectadores que
estamos haciendo un festival un Perdón
un cubrimiento especial de este festival
como todos los años Así que les invito a
que vean tu Crónica de cultura de todas
las semanas y también nuestro
cubrimiento del festival